We'll now have a look at the domain name system or DNS. The purpose of
the domain name system is to map human readable names such
www.gatech.edu to
IP addresses such as 130.207.160.173.
A name such as this is human readable and much easier to remember and type than
an IP address. But in fact, the IP address
is what's needed to send traffic to the intended destination.
So, we need a look up mechanism that takes
a human readable name and maps it to an IP
address. The system that does this is a Domain
Name System, or the DNS. They system roughly works as
follows the client may want to look up a
domain name such as www dot [UNKNOWN] edu the network
application source code might do so by invoking
a function such as get host by name. Which
takes as an argument a domain name and
returns an IP address. The client typically has what's
called a stub resolver, and that stub resolver
takes that name and issues a query. The stub
resolver might have cached the answer or the
IP address corresponding to this name but if not,
the query is sent to what's called a
local DNS resolver. Your local DNS resolver, is typically
configured automatically when your host is assigned an IP
address using a protocol called the domain host control
protocol or DHCP. In your host configuration such as
this one, you can see that this local host
has two local DNS resolvers. Typically, a client will
try the first DNS resolver and if it doesn't
receive a response within a preconfigured timeout, it will
try sending the same query To the second local
DNS resolver as a backup. This query is typically
issued recursively, meaning the client does not want intermediate
referrals sent back to it. It only wants to
hear when it's received the final answer. The local
resolver on the other hand will perform iterative queries.
It might have the answer, to this particular query,
in the cache in which case it would
simply reply with the answer. But let's suppose for
the moment, that nothing is cached, each fully qualified
domain name is presumed to end with a dot,
indicating the root of the DNS hierarchy. Now
the IP addresses for the root servers, or those
that are authoritative for the root may already be
configured in the local DNS resolver. In this case,
the resolver may be able to query for
the authoritative server for .edu and say a.rootservers
Dot net. This would be an a record
query. The answer might return with what's called an
NS record which is a referral. In this case the answer might be a referral to
the edu servers. Now the local resolver issues
the same query to the edu servers and receives
a referral to the authoritative servers For
gatech.edu. Finally the local resolver might query the authoritative name server
for gatech.edu and actually receive an A record indicating
the actual IP address that corresponds to that name.